all right guys
bang bang got a special treat i've got
griffin johnson here what's going on man
dude i uh i know i've seen you a lot
around with bryce
and doing uh you guys thing on your
podcast i actually thought about wearing
a wife beater
um you know i figured that might bring
our chemistry up a little bit because
you're used to it with bryce
but uh yeah dude i'm excited to be here
man listen you're don't lie to the
people when we first started you were
going to do without a shirt on and i
said hey you can do that if you want but
it uh it passes with my audience but you
know
um a lot of these guys here they either
a their kids know me and they think i'm
a doofus
or b they have no clue who i am so you
know
i figured i i should probably present
myself a little better
all right let's go through your
background uh
you have one of the largest followings
on tick tock today but
where'd you grow up and kind of how did
you get into creating content on the
internet
yeah so you know i grew up um
right on the border of indiana and
illinois
pretty much central but considered south
doesn't really matter
but uh yeah i didn't grow up with uh you
know a lot of money my dad is
uh he works in the factory my mom ended
up going back to school for nursing so i
always had to hustle
which kind of brought in my entrepreneur
my entrepreneurship
and i went into college
and i was in nursing school at the time
and you know i played sports and
baseball that jazz
but uh my second semester my sophomore
year
i uh i was in a class all girls nursing
you know how it goes
and they all do the social media stuff
and i was never really into it
posted maybe twice a year on instagram
total bro thought it was stupid
laughed at all the social media creators
and youtubers that the girls would drool
over
and uh a bunch of girls in my class were
making tick tocks and i was in them and
they would do well because i'm in my
scrubs and they're like oh who's the
nurse guy who's the nurse guy
and i was growing on instagram like
crazy
and i was like what is going on and i
guess they were putting my handle on
there
and it wasn't until i saw a girl
literally
as we were studying for an exam went
live on tick tock and made like a
hundred bucks
i was like are you kidding me so
i tried it out posted a video it blew up
i woke up the next day with like 20
000 followers um what was the video
it was just me and my scrubs and i was
in class
sitting there and said got my phone
taken away for this and it was just me
sitting there
got like a hundred thousand likes blew
up and i was like all right
and from then on i just saw the easy
money i didn't have an actual idea of
being a content creator social media kid
whatever you want to call it
um but yeah i just i literally just
wanted the revenue from the streams
because i was a broke college kid
i worked in a factory every summer to
have enough money to get through the
school year because i couldn't work
because of my school and nursing and
stuff so
yeah that was my whole goal was to just
keep making videos and i was trying to
grow my followers to
get that revenue off the streams and
three months later i think i had 100
something k
went to uh one of the social media
events because
i met some kids and they um you know one
of them's anthony that lives with me now
and uh yeah i just went on tour met the
boys
after that met bryce we made this way
house and uh
that's the short form for basically how
i got here yeah
and so when you talk about uh making
money off the streams most people listen
to this are gonna have no clue what that
means so explain
how people get paid for the actual
streams so how it is
you um you know there's a for you page
so if your video is going viral it gets
on the for you page
um and then a live stream is there's a
live feature on tick tock itself on the
platform just like in instagram live
you just click a button you go live
people can join in
and basically if your video especially
is on the for you page people will see
that you're live they can click in
or just your fans and um basically it's
just a donation system
so there's like different levels like a
dollar two dollars
five ten fifteen twenty fifty um and
people can send you money and then you
basically give incentives like
you know i'll put you in a drawing for
my merch or you can literally just sit
there and do nothing and
people will actually donate just to like
you know laugh and enjoy the content
but um yeah and then tick tock holds it
in their bank for a couple days
um you know and people you can only draw
out a thousand dollars
so basically tick tock makes bank off of
interest just by having it there
so it's it's that's kind of why they do
it and how it works for the creator
when you go live right now how much
money would you make
um depending on the time obviously uh my
standard is usually 20 minutes and i'll
make anywhere from like
you know 1500 to 2 grand you realize
that's ridiculous right
yeah it's absolutely insane uh but i
actually quit doing it as i became more
successful
just because like in the beginning i
needed it now i kind of leave it for the
other creators
that you know need that because it
really helped my career and
helped me out a lot and just in life in
general
so i don't really do it anymore um some
people say you should
i feel kind of dirty you know being
successful and having my own other
streams and
uh revenue and still taking money from
you know 12
to 10 to 16 year old girls that are
probably using their dad's
credit cards so i kind of quit doing it
but it's definitely
a really good way to make money do you
feel bad taking it from the girls or
from
their dads um both
for one i feel bad for the girls mainly
because i'm not really that cool so why
are you sending me money to sit there
and then i also feel bad for the dads
because you know they're going to work
just so their daughter can pay some
douche bag on the internet just
talk to the camera so
you know it goes both ways that's fair
um so i've talked to bryce about it but
i know most people in the audience won't
understand how you guys are
making money outside of just those
streams so let's just kind of
walk through like the world of griffin
in terms of what else do you do with
your time so like
maybe like let's go through a day so
what time do you wake up what do you do
all day and then how do you make money
so um i call this early because it's
early in social media but i'm usually up
like awake at like 8 30 out of bed ready
for the day at nine
which is early in our world probably not
for people listening to this they're
probably like wow you're lazy
but um yeah that's kind of how this
industry works it's later a lot of kids
don't wake up until
noon so start calls at 10
which is um you know usually later on
the east coast time so sometimes i wake
up earlier seven i'll have calls at
seven
sometimes if they're four and i've had
calls at like midnight
um which is all western time obviously
but uh yeah so i wake up calls start at
10
i'm usually at bryce's house the vest on
house where he records
um by like 9 9 like
9 15 9 20 and then we sit down we have
our
every day scheduled out on a google
calendar um
it's usually consists of anywhere from
like four to eight calls
usually at least one sit-down meeting a
day where someone comes in or we
got dinner especially before everything
got locked down um and then
every day around like 11 00 to noon it's
just
a time blocked out for filming tick
tocks and
getting all your content posting on
instagram whatever it is
and then on mondays and thursdays now
they are basically like designated film
days for youtube
podcasts you know you and bryce do
tuesdays because that fits you better
but for me obviously i wouldn't do it
the same day so
yeah it's it's very structured i think
people think we kind of just sit on our
ass and like
just go with the flow and like post tic
talks all day
definitely not it um you know it's
it's very structured and we that's how
we get into all these investments and
you know we've really pivoted out from
being these [ __ ] that
got their water and power shut off to
now angel investors and
um i actually just became a consultant
advisor for red global
which is one of the biggest esports
teams in the entire world
um as well as you know we got triller
and some other things working in the mix
so yeah it's um basically calls
content um and obviously you know trips
and stuff come up but
that's the normal day yeah and uh i'm
not just saying it to you
obviously people know that uh i've been
spending all this time with bryce but
like you guys do work your asses off and
and i
agree with you that most people don't
realize uh kind of how structured it is
i remember the first time he told me
about like the content day sounds like
what do you mean you block off two days
he's like yeah like that's all we do is
we just you know ideate
you know film edit like do all this kind
of stuff and when you look at the
content
output that you guys do like you have to
dedicate a lot of time to it
it just takes the time um when you're
doing all this stuff
where does the money come from so uh are
you getting paid brand deals
are you doing you know youtube revenue
merchandise
like where do you kind of think of your
income from coming from
right so this is like a really
really highly asked question and it
always changes a little bit because
things come up and
you know but i would say it's very very
dynamic and depends on the creator so
this isn't for like you know bryce has
different answers than i do
but um i will give you the basis so
a lot of creators they have youtube so
google adsense you get paid you you get
basically a cpm i don't know if people
know how that works
but um per thousand views um you usually
get a
set dollar amount that's given to you by
youtube six seven
it's usually in that six seven range um
so there's that it comes in every month
you get paid once a month by that
um you obviously can do your a lot of
people do the tick tock live streams or
um you know now there's a feature on
instagram you can do that which is
really good money
i mean if you're making a thousand
dollars a day you can make
you know 30 grand a month off of just
that
obviously you got brand deals so those
for anyone that doesn't know what a
brand deal is
you can get paid from anything from
using a sound on tick tock to doing uh
you know a promotion on an instagram
feed post where you
shout out whatever company and tag them
um those are usually pretty nice and pay
well
and uh how much do those pay like or how
do you think about
you know if somebody came to you and
said hey i want you to do this how do
you think about pricing it
so for me it it it comes into a lot of
things is it static which means you know
does it
are you keeping it up forever um is it a
couple days
and then i i know you've probably seen
these before you have to follow like
everyone someone's following or whatever
those are super like non-organic and
they look
literally ridiculous on your page so i
try to steer away but if you know the
money's right
obviously um someone asked me to do
those it's going to be more
i would say for let's just say midline
of all the sway boys
500 000 likes uh you should probably get
about
you know 50k for a post i would say is
like a rough number depending on what
they want
um and for someone that gets 500 000
likes that's obviously like
2 million um you know people engaged
with it at least
minimum you know 1.8 to 2 million so if
you think about it
social media creators are kind of um
underpaid in the eyeball sense for like
you know marketing on like tv
i don't i can't name a single show
really on anymore on tv that gets
two million um eyeballs at once
so um so you got the brand deals what
else
yeah um let's see
i'm trying to think um do you have merch
yeah oh yeah that's a big point i don't
do merch that's why i didn't
um come to the top of my head but yeah
merch is definitely you know bryce says
his brand and
there's a lot of creators that build
brands off of themselves that sell well
why don't you do merch the reason i
don't do merch anymore is because it's a
really
over saturated market think about how
many hoodies you have in your closet and
how many of them you actually wear
um and you know i have literally i'm
looking at 20 hoodies that are all
really cool
brands sent them to me they were free
whatever uh
probably won't ever wear them not
because they're not cool but just
because like
everyone has a million hoodies and
t-shirts nowadays
and not only that it's just a really
hard market because every single
creator it's like not a creative idea
every single creator is like oh i get
100 000 followers oh
here's my merch link my teespring
um so yeah it's just a market that's
like the margins aren't great you're
talking like
you know you're selling a hoodie for
fifty dollars and by the time you pay
for shipping everything you're making
like
i don't know six bucks
what's the most ridiculous thing anyone
uh
that you know kind of in this influencer
content creator world has done
for money uh i would say
probably um only fans
uh and the reason i say that is like
only fans can bring in like a lot of
money don't get me wrong
but they like they fake like they're
putting like an explicit picture on
there
and they think they're gonna like get
everyone and then basically all it does
is everyone tries to refund their money
and then it takes only fans like
that's just one example i've seen people
uh fake being in the hospital i've seen
people
like fake breaking up like it's just
crazy stupid [ __ ]
that i don't even understand so you
really can't
predict these creator kids because
they're literally wild so
yeah how do you guys come up with the
ideas for the videos like like you
bryce josh except like the videos that
you guys are producing
are uh usually have some level of
entertainment to them
and so how do you guys come up with
those ideas yeah so
um it it does become a routine
um honestly like once you get in the
space you kind of see things and know
things that work and
you learn from other people and kind of
tweak it so i would say a lot of our
ideas come from other people in the past
or trends that are working at the
time and then we just literally ramp it
up make it bigger
spice it up add our own twist to it
but a lot of it is just being involved
in kind of the space and seeing what
other people are doing and what has
worked in the past or what's currently
working
um and obviously sometimes you know
things just come to you on the fly
it's not like we just sit i don't think
anyone really just sits down for hours
and like thinks of a video
it's just kind of one of those things
where you just roll with what's going
that week
and think about it on the fly yeah
when you think of kind of this creator
space today
what's like the average kid make right
are we talking
not not as much as you think okay so so
help me understand like what like what's
the most somebody makes
and what's kind of the average okay so
i'm just gonna say
it's a little bit different it depends
there's so many factors in social media
that kind of
mediate how much money you make so
um i have 20 million followers across
all platforms
if i only did brand deals and i grinded
live streams i'm talking like
every day i would say i'd probably make
500k
in a year okay which you know
that's that's not shabby but like you
think someone with 20 million followers
they're making like 10 million dollars
um but that also is because of sway
our previous brand and we're kind of
fixing that
but that's also why we pivoted and it
forced us to create our own companies
and build our own brands and
that's why i'm literally here talking to
you right now is because
we can't do brand deals i would say the
average
um for the average creator let's say two
million followers
on tick tock and let's say they're
completely clean
i'd say they're making maybe like 15 20k
a month
okay now explain because again most
people aren't going to know all of the
uh
i'll call it the drama or the
controversy uh when you're talking about
a clean creator versus a non-clean
creator and the sway stuff
it help people understand kind of uh
from a brand's perspective
why are they unwilling to either work
with you guys or pay you less compared
to
a quote-unquote clean creator right so
someone that's clean is like
you know i wouldn't even say cussing
like those are like extreme disney kids
um but it's like you know with sway
we've we've drank on camera um vaped on
camera
you know whatever um been drunk on
camera
and obviously there's been fights and
you know the boys got in trouble in the
past
some legal trouble and stuff so that's
like that's really extreme bad
um the party the party yeah the part
yeah the party with the power um i don't
even think that got as much negative
backlash as people think
um people obviously it's the only thing
that people
that i talk to when they're like oh who
are these guys
and i'll be you know try to explain or
whatever and then somebody in the group
will always be like oh that's the kid
who got the power shut off right that's
the group you got the power shut off
and i'm like yeah they don't care that
it got shut off right because they
understand that young kids are gonna
party whatever
but that's like the one moment where i
think you guys like definitely arrived
more than you thought you did well like
the thing is i
honestly think it's kind of i get it
from a brand perspective because it's
like
if we work with sway what are they gonna
do like are they gonna get a fight are
they gonna tarnish our name
um but honestly if i and this isn't
being like prejudice at all this is just
like
if i were a brand and i wasn't
like disney pg obviously and didn't have
like
that um one thing that i that i've seen
is a lot of those clean creators do not
convert at
all because brands think that they are
paying to get all these views and all
these fans
but in reality all their followers just
follow their content they could give a
crap less
like they'll have 20 million on tick
tock and they'll get
50 000 likes on instagram i get more
than that on my backup account
my third backup account my dog gets more
likes than that on
it's like it's crazy because
you know i i get it in a sense but at
the same time it's like
people stop conversion it's conversion
it's like what are you gonna pay for
for people to see it like okay i guess
that i mean that is a strategy but um
it's just crazy to me and i don't think
a lot of people understand
the actual dynamics of social media and
how many things you
have to look at when you're doing a
brand deal or you're working with a kid
that is in the social media space
all right before we get into the
business and investing stuff uh how old
are you
i'm 21. all right as 21 you're rich and
famous right
for all intents and purposes uh i got to
imagine
that you get hit up by all kinds of
ridiculous crazy people
all kinds of girls dm and you etc
what is your life like well if you talk
to like a friend from home
that you grew up with who like doesn't
understand how this all happened
how do you explain to them your life
compared to you know
three years ago four years ago yeah so
um you know i would humbly say that i'm
pretty rooted from my
from my hometown i'm still friends with
a bunch of you know so
uh i think most creators you know have
drifted
a lot from you know from when they
started and i've definitely changed in
my ways
i would say the biggest pivot is
um me actually thinking about others
using me because i'm from a small town
you know
farm i worked in factories it's like if
someone needs help you're there it's
like
yo my cow's out can you come nah
it's not like yo are you trying to use
me
it's like a community of people that are
like that help each other anytime like
you know there's guys that would plow my
driveway
um when it's snow or like whatever and
you don't have to pay them
you just like get them back later uh so
one of the biggest things is is how
ruthless people are um
and i struggle with this really bad
because i'm such a helpful person
um i want to help people and you know do
my best to be
a respectful dude uh really learn fast
that
that doesn't work in la people don't
give a [ __ ] um there's not a lot of
morals
so that's a really big uh struggle with
me and i feel like
you know a lot of common people and
especially either from the south or
midwest can definitely
relate to that because i never saw any
business growing up there was no really
businesses
my dad didn't know anything about
business or anyone in my family for that
matter so
uh that was a really big struggle that i
had
and then obviously there's the parties
the girls the temptations
you know growing up it was like yo
bonfire in the corn field like
let's go saturday boy bush light you
know it wasn't like anything crazy
now you got like you go on my dms i get
a thousand dms a day from all these like
models and girls with their asses out
and everything are you responding
i used to i really did uh when we were
in our old sway house and really on our
[ __ ]
i would go through and respond of course
i was trying to talk to girls
luckily ended up getting a girlfriend
and slowed down for a really long time
and then
afterwards uh you know there's a bunch
of drama and
i ended up you know snapchatting your
girl and after that whole drama went
down and i got cooked on the internet
like genuinely no [ __ ] i learned my
lesson i
barely even look at my dms anymore but
it is
absolutely crazy because sometimes i
catch myself talking it's like
dude i hate when girls like just send me
their asses and i can't respond and my
friends are like
that's never happened to me dude
so yeah that's that's definitely a thing
and then the last thing i would say is
just
um always being aware in public so
um i'm just gonna be straight up my
lingo from being in indiana like
you know i was really insensitive to a
lot of things that here in l.a are like
really big problems
so that was the first one is having a
microscope and obviously
you know checking my language and
checking the things that i do
because um obviously i'm not from a
culture that
thinks about a lot of things like that
and uh just making sure like i'm always
on my [ __ ]
like when i'm driving my car you know i
got caught one time picking my nose
and it's like who really gives a [ __ ]
you know
but at the same time it's like really
man
and uh that's definitely one of the
biggest changes is like even being out
with my family when they visit la it's
like
my family doesn't want to be like seen
like that so
it's just what do they think what do
they think about what do they think
about all that
uh in my dad's words
he said well feller i don't really know
what you're doing
but it's working so they don't really
have social media my dad has like one of
those industrial smartphones that's like
works at negative 10 seconds um you know
per minute so
it's uh my brother he he's a working guy
he's going to trade school for linemen
to be a lineman and my mom like she
hears things more
obviously because she's a lot more
emotional and she doesn't really check
my socials that much
but her friends at work she's a nurse
now she just recently went to nursing
school
finished that so her friends you know
they gossip and it's like
the work room did you see griffin's with
this girl you know and she'll text me
about it but
other than that they don't they don't
get worked up um
they don't really care that much if i'm
famous or if i'm
homeless so yeah i love it uh let's talk
about business and investing
uh you along with the rest of the guys
have really kind of
uh taken this hard right and started
angel investing a lot
starting companies how do you just think
about like why
right like why are you interested in
this stuff right so
like i mentioned briefly earlier you
know growing up i hustled
um just because i didn't have a lot of
money i definitely wasn't like
you know homeless but uh we were just a
normal
low middle class middle class family so
if i wanted anything or if i wanted
anything extra
i would have to work extra hard to get
money from the kids that did have money
so whatever it was like i used to hustle
like
um you know make sports bets like i'll
beat you in this basketball game or
it started off kind of like that and um
you know as i got into social media
stuff i didn't really
understand like how it could be used but
i've always had an
interest in business so
um you know just making that pivot out
because we didn't get any brand deals
like i said because we were [ __ ]
um we had to find an alternative and
then
as soon as we started doing things and
starting our own brands i
i literally just it clicked with me i
fell in love and i'm like wow this
this makes sense like if i want to make
money that's actually going to you know
create generational wealth and set me up
so i don't have to work
um you know i had no other choice
so i kind of fell into it already kind
of loved it
and had no other choice do you enjoy
like the business building
um and kind of operating stuff or the
investing more or maybe like both
um i like aspects of both
i the reason i don't like um that i
well actually i'm gonna change the
answer i do like building more
um the thing that scared me away at
first was i was afraid to fail
like i'm a very like textbook like we're
gonna make
this much money and then it gives me
something to work towards
um something that i even had in my
social media career
and definitely with building businesses
is i was afraid to like
make something that wouldn't work
instead of doing something that i really
loved and making it work
so um building something is something
i haven't done it yet i'm working on it
really hard right now and it's really
challenging me
investing is cool because you get to
meet a lot of people
obviously and you know it's kind of one
of those things i'm going to do
for anything that i can't build or the
boys can't build
it's and i want to be a part of it i
believe in it i just put my money into
it
so i would say for me they go kind of
almost hand in hand because
even if i'm not building it um
personally or the boys aren't
i'm investing in it because i want to
help build it with my following
which is kind of what i've been doing
you know i'm working on a couple
investments that haven't been signed yet
and then
i have uh the wrecked deal where i'm an
actual consultant
and i'm literally i can't build a gaming
team because i don't have time
but i'm using their resources and using
my following to connect the dots
so got it and so what's the conversation
been like with founders right
as people have found out that you're
starting to invest how has that
reception been and kind of what those
conversations were like
um when i first started it was a lot
different than now when i had no
investments it was like
um you know how well do you convert like
what can you do for us um you know
and like they just basically if they
if they talk to me they wanted the
social media following it's like can you
get me verified on twitter can you
retweet things for me
like whatever which is cool but i was
like
i don't really like that's weird unless
i really [ __ ] with you i'm not gonna do
that
um but now it's definitely converted
over to it's
a lot more serious we kind of have you
know we're on a lot of cap tables and
you know a lot of people are talking
about us now they're like are these kids
really serious are they about it are
they worth it
and we've kind of proven ourselves um
you know andy's doing a lot of cool
things and
um you know some of our other investors
we've been in you know they they mention
us all the time and
uh it's it's definitely changing slowly
from
what can you do for us to you know
or i guess how can you help us to what
can you do for us and help
like get us there yeah and do you guys
talk internally at the house like
if one of you sees a deal you'll bring
it back to everyone and kind of say hey
look i saw this like i think it's cool
what do you guys think
or are each of you kind of making
decisions on your own without really
talking about with each other um
everything we do is together i mean
literally there's you know josh has a
couple things he's done on his own and i
have a couple things i've done on my own
as well as bryce
but we all know what's going on it's
it's a team
um obviously we're way more powerful as
a group than we are just individually
so literally everything we do runs
through you know
the boys and michael and whoever the
team is and then me
so um definitely just a big group and we
really like to bundle ourselves up and
bring as much punch as we can
uh you mentioned michael michael gruen
uh kind of i don't even know what what
exactly does michael
consider his title or role to be right
well that's a good thing we
that's a good thing to ask because we
always get really confused and battle
back and forth of what we call him
um he started off basically as just
being a mentor
and he kind of wanted to be an advisor
in talonx which is you know
him and josh founded it and then we all
started it from scratch
um so he started off wanting to just be
an advisor kind of help us out and
guide us in the right direction ended up
now he literally
helped us build this way house does
every single deal we do
like he gets pressed for us like he does
literally everything but i would
consider him
more importantly my business partner
i see myself working with him for a
really long time and i truly believe
that
you know he's a prodigy he can literally
make money
with the click of his fingers if he
wants to so he's doing a fantastic job
and he definitely works hard
uh but now that we've said nice things
about him you've got to tell us what's
the funniest michael gruen story you
have
dude not the it's not a story with him
but michael one time did a tick tock
with me
um at our old house and it's like don't
worry about me i'm a thug
and it's like i actually retweeted an
edit of it because my
fans made an edit of michael um doing
the dance and it's like a fan page edit
and now they they put hashtag gruengang
under his tweets and stuff and it is so
funny because they tagged me in edits of
him all the time and it's like
you know he he he's the guy on instagram
that'll post pictures and the only time
is
when it's with someone like famous or
important that he's friends with or has
met
um so they'll make jokes out of it and
they'll be like you know
uh you know how we tweet about the
business stuff like
yo at whoever really interested in what
you're doing want to get invested like
want to learn from you
they'll like take those tweets and then
change it and then tweet at him
and it's so fun
we better be careful or that literally
is going to become a thing and he's
going to be embarrassed
uh it already is it already is
i love it before i let you go i always
ask everyone the same two questions and
you'll get to ask me one uh to finish
up what's the most important book you
think you've ever read
oh goodness um
man that's really important or or
content doesn't have to actually be a
book but just like what's the most
important piece of
youtube video uh podcast book whatever
um i think i might actually have it
right next to me
um let's see i was gonna pull it up but
i don't know exactly where it is but
i have a book and um basically it
it digests like a lot of like motley
crew and all
all of the old um you know like um
alternative and punk rock and rock bands
did
and it kind of breaks down the meta of
like how they
um you know built their brands and kind
of created that legacy
i don't know oh here it is yeah it's
called please kill me
um and it's really cool and i think it
works for
business even and uh i like it because a
lot of people think social media
creators aren't smart
um or you know they don't know what
they're doing and it's kind of the same
thing with them when you think of a punk
rock do you think of some do with long
hair black nails like screaming into a
mic
and it's it died just basically how
every successful
you know rock banding group ever became
and there's actually like a system to it
and it really just inspired me to do
that with myself and
um build my own brand so let them
underestimate you man
you guys are way smarter than uh than
they think uh second question is more
fun aliens are you a believer or
non-believer
um dude it's like
i i i think i'm crazy when i say yes
but at the same time it's like there has
to be other life forms out there
there of course so i would say um i'm
beating around the bush but the answer
is yes
i think there's probably something out
there for sure
anyone who's an alien uh like
non-believer they're just the trolls on
twitter
there's a high correlation between
trolls on twitter and people who don't
believe in aliens
yeah we'll see the thing is when you say
alien i don't think it's a little green
dude flying around
ufo but yeah
all right good clarify that so there's
not headlines of griffin johnson
believes aliens are flying in ufos
uh yeah there's there's something now
all right you could ask me one question
to finish up what do you got for me
right so um one question i have for you
is is do you recommend people
um you know buying bitcoin even if it's
not a full bitcoin
obviously because it's really expensive
especially right now um
do you think it's still worth it and i
know this is another question to add it
on top of it do you think it's
actually going to be worth i think 314k
by 2025.
uh i don't know where the 314k number
came from but
uh from the from the twins i believe
it's right around there it's right
around that 300k
mark okay so here here's how i think
about it right so one is
uh you're writing that you don't have to
buy a full bitcoin right so
full bitcoin's like 19 000 right now
well you can definitely buy a piece of
it and
here's why i think that people should
own bitcoin right is
just think 10 years from now do you
think more people are going to be using
bitcoin or less people
are going to be using bitcoin than they
are today probably more
i would say i would say more especially
as the us dollar
you know depreciates and the government
keeps getting a lot more unstable
um so you know trust in the dollar keeps
going down so
it's like two percent at least every
year it appreciates from inflation
yeah so if you think of that right just
there's going to be more people using it
right and adopting it in the future
today it's a fixed supply asset so the
just naturally supplied demand economics
the price
has to go up in us dollar trends over a
very very long period of time
but i always say very very long period
of time because what people get
you know kind of caught on is they buy
something today and whether it goes up
or down they panic
right if it goes up a bunch they sell it
if it goes down they sell it right
but if you basically just say hey look
i'm basically going to
dollar cost average in right buy a
little bit you know every day or every
monday or every month or whatever it is
and i'm just going to accumulate more
and more of this and i'm going to hold
it for a long period of time
it'll work out right because of the
supply demand kind of economics but i
think that having a long time horizon is
really important
um you know and like right now
everyone's
buying every stock in the world and
bitcoin and all this crazy stuff's
happening but you just gotta remember
it's like the longer term
uh time horizon you have the more
advantage you have
uh yeah that's it that's a good point
because i was um
i bought my first bitcoin but i was very
hesitant because
i didn't want to spend i think at the
time it was like
i bought it like 15 430 something
and i was like [ __ ] i don't want to pay
15 grand
and then you know like a month went not
even a month like a week and a half went
by and it was already up
close to like 19 and i was like
oh all right well maybe i should have
bought more
yeah um but i still had on to it and i
think after the election stuff dies down
it'll probably drop again
um i'm assuming but yeah uh i'm
definitely gonna hold on to that for a
while and i think
you know there's only what 21 million
that you can acquire total in the world
so there's going to be a time whenever
it gets really sticky
i love it man i would ask where we can
send people to find you on the internet
but i don't think that's going to be
very hard for most people to find you
where do you want them to go where
should they go follow you if they're
interested in
all the business and finance stuff i do
want to say i just started a linkedin
i'm very proud of that i never had one
so you know if you guys want to connect
you guys can find me on there but just
my name
um obviously and then uh i guess twitter
no one else wants to see me
shirtless uh dancing around so if you
i tweet about some investments of course
i throw in some stuff for the girls on
twitter
but um every now and again i'll put some
interesting business advice or
talk to some cool people on twitter so
um and my twitter is like
i'm griffin johnson but the eyes and l
so i'm sure you can just type in my name
and find it
i love it man listen thank you so much
for doing this you guys are doing a
fantastic job
you know as i told you guys before donut
don't worry about what everyone else is
saying
you guys are working hard you're making
money and you're investing so
that's literally the dream thanks for uh
thanks for letting me get on here and
explain to people that you know i'm dumb
but just not as dumb as what they say
all right man we'll do it again in the
future thanks pomp